if you are capable of understanding the
words I'm speaking right now chances are
you're conscious and that makes you
rather special since the vast majority
of things in our universe lack
Consciousness but you've been conscious
for so much of your life that you
probably take it for granted you're used
to it and you don't realize how weird
human consciousness is consciousness of
course is your internal awareness of
your thoughts your feelings your
memories your experiences of the
external world and so on seems pretty
straightforward but whether you try to
examine it through the lens of biology
or psychology or philosophy things get
very confusing very quickly now on the
one hand Consciousness is foundational
it's required even for what we're doing
right now in order to ponder our place
in the universe and to ask difficult
questions s and to desire answers and to
find certain explanations satisfying or
unsatisfying we need our human
consciousness we can't do what we're
doing right now without it so we know
that whatever it is we've got it and
that it's important but on the other
hand trying to figure out exactly what
Consciousness is how we got it how it
works that discussion leads to Serious
difficulties the main dividing line here
is between people who believe that
Consciousness can ultimately be
explained in terms of the physical
workings of our brains and people who
believe that Consciousness cannot
ultimately be explained in terms of the
physical workings of our brains what I
find most interesting about this
discussion is that even as students are
being assured by their teachers that the
experts have Consciousness all figured
out bunch of neurons firing the experts
are admitting that they have Absol
absolutely no clue what's going on and
this is causing some people who used to
think that Consciousness is simply
particles interacting in your brain to
doubt that position and to start looking
for other
explanations let's consider two examples
Jordan Peterson the psychologist and
Adam Savage the mythbuster we'll start
with Dr Peterson no one knows how life
arose no one knows anything about
Consciousness not not the least it's a
byproduct of neural activity it's why
why isn't your solar plexus conscious
then Peterson mocks the standard
explanation the standard explanation is
that Consciousness is just a byproduct
of neural
activity your solar plexus is called the
solar plexus because nerves radiate from
it like light radiates from the Sun why
isn't your solar plexus conscious if
consciousness is a byproduct of neural
activity right you've got neurons Galore
there's more neurons in your autonomic
nervous system than there in are in your
central nervous system it's not
conscious it's not neural activity per
se and most neural activity in your
cerebral cortex isn't conscious what the
hell is consciousness so you can't just
say neural activity and pretend that
this explains Consciousness at the very
least you'd have to explain why this
neural activity over here gives rise to
consciousness while all this other
neural activity doesn't and some of you
are thinking well that's exactly what
we'll do we'll explain why the neural
activity here gives rise to
Consciousness while other neural
activity doesn't but again this leads to
some serious problems materialists
believe that awareness thoughts emotions
hopes decisions and so on are all just
physical states in the
brain but it doesn't seem like beliefs
or thoughts can be physical brain States
because beliefs or thoughts have
properties that physical things don't
have for instance my beliefs can be true
or false it makes no sense to say that
an arrangement of particles in my brain
is true or false this arrangement of
particles is true but this arrangement
of particles is
false what would that even
mean I have thoughts that are about
other things it makes no sense to say
that this pattern of neurons right here
is about something else I can have a
thought about a grilled cheese sandwich
I can't have a pattern of neurons about
a grilled cheese sandwich if a scientist
examines my brain he might learn all
kinds of things about my brain that I
don't know but he'll never learn more
about my mind than I know if a scientist
wants to know what's in my brain he can
give me an MRI scan if he wants to know
what's in my mind he has to ask
me so even though the mind and the brain
are closely linked they have different
features and different properties so how
can they be the same
thing perhaps we need a better
definition the hell's Consciousness it's
the spirit of God that that what would
you say Broods a upon the face of the
waters that's right that's what
Consciousness is yeah that's the that's
as good a definition as any in fact it's
the best definition I've ever seen
Genesis 1:2 the spirit of God was
hovering over the face of the waters
Peterson likes that as a definition of
Consciousness the spirit is hovering
over the material to bring order to
chaos not very precise if you're looking
for a clear scientific definition of
Consciousness but I think that's the
point you're not going to get a clear
scientific materialist definition of
Consciousness because whatever it is it
goes beyond the
material so the best definition we have
may be something like it's the spirit of
God that that what would you say Broods
upon the face of the waters that's right
that's what Consciousness is yeah now
for Adam Savage of mythbust
Fame Savage used to work with the
so-called new atheists he even spoke at
the 2012 reason rally the reason rallies
were like ComiCon for atheists to
cosplay as people who are smarter than
everyone else so they'd all get together
and brag about how unlike dumb religious
people atheists test their beliefs and
only go where the evidence
points testable provable phenomena and
the addictions they allow big and small
brought me here in front of you today
and they will take me back to my family
when I am done testable provable
phenomena that's what gets things done
unlike all your religious
delusions everything that we have that
makes our lives possible exists because
human beings have tested the things they
found in their surroundings made
predictions based on those tests and
then improved upon them we we test we
make predictions and we make
improvements you got that religious
people this is reason the human capacity
to make sense of the
world W woo we're the champions of
reason but remember his definition of
reason the human capacity to make sense
of the world reason according to myth
Buster Adam Savage is the human capacity
to make sense of the world hold that
thought as Neil degrass Tyson
says facts are true whether or not you
believe
them woo woo he quoted Neil degrass
Tyson that's an atheist facts are true
take that religion
tards I have concluded through careful
empirical analysis and much thought that
somebody is looking out for me keeping
track of what I think about things
forgiving me when I do less than I ought
is it God is he about to say
God giving me strength to shoot for more
than I think I'm capable of I believe
they know everything that I do and think
and they still love me and I've
concluded after careful consideration
that this person keeping score is
me aw and here we thought thought he was
going to say
God well now you know what it was like
to be at a reason rally yeah when the
speaker says science a reason that's
when I yell
woo that mean I'm more smarter than you
my
goodness 3.7 billion years ago a clown
Emoji formed by chance in the primordial
soup after millions of generations of
mutation and selection that clown Emoji
became a rally the reason
rally but that was Adam in 2012 it's
2024 now and Adam no longer rolls with
the new
atheists the Daniel Saltzman wants to
know would you be willing to share your
current outlook on the grand mysteries
of
life I recall times in the past when
you've been an outspoken religious
skeptic uh I.E atheist and then later
you distan yourself from that label uh
that's true because too many people were
being
jerks you went to rallies whose only
purpose was to say we're smart and other
people are dumb and you finally realized
that they were a bunch of
jerks well the Skeptics movement itself
sort of devolved uh into several
factions nothing devolves quite like an
atheist movement and now more recently
I've noticed you quoting people people
like Romas here in the live streams are
you getting more mystical as you get
older no first of all no there have been
multiple gurus named ramas so I'm not
sure which one he's referring to but
let's just say he's not talking about a
scientist here it's true I no longer say
atheist because it's actually still
defining myself in terms of an
impression of a god a theist non God he
no longer consider ERS himself an
atheist because he regards atheism as a
position on the existence of God and he
doesn't affirm that
position as a scientist I can't know
that something doesn't exist that's
that's an impossible thing to know I
can't know if there's a Consciousness
that tipped to the first Domino
over so that places me in in the
agnostic Camp I believe
he's no longer an atheist he's an
agnostic he doesn't know it's a small
step in the right direction I jokingly
refer to myself as a new testament
agnostic because I can't know and I
believe I agree with pretty much
everything Jesus says in the New
Testament it's hard to argue uh with his
lovely philosophy on people he's a new
testament agnostic that that is an
interesting position he doesn't mean
that he's an agnostic about the New
Testament he's an agnostic about the
existence of God but he otherwise agrees
with the teachings of Jesus in the New
Testament I have always been incredibly
scientifically minded if you if you tell
me a ghost story I am going to think
about ways in which your impression of
what you remember might be wrong same
page here I believe in the Supernatural
but that doesn't mean I believe
everything anyone thinks is Supernatural
and so if you told me you saw a ghost
I'd be pretty skeptical about that and I
would look for other
explanations I am not getting more
mystical as I get older but I am more
fascinated by the absolute Miracle of
our sence of our of our ability to know
ourselves and to look out into the world
and understand things at these meta
levels that the cells in here somehow do
two important points there he says he's
fascinated by the absolute Miracle of
our sensient he's referring to
Consciousness there's something really
amazing about
it but then he says that it's the cells
in our brains that are somehow doing it
given what he's about to say in a few
moments he doesn't seem to believe that
it's merely the cells in our
brains and the AI the the Advent of AI
in the last in the last couple years has
only served to strengthen to me the
mystery of what Consciousness is it
seems to me the most Central mystery how
would the Advent of AI deepen the
mystery of
Consciousness I thought we were getting
closer and closer to something like
human
consciousness well think about it
we've got very intelligent people with
very fancy degrees in multi-million doll
labs around the world working tirelessly
to improve AI hoping that after many
many years of hard work they'll end up
producing something like human
consciousness but human consciousness
happened on its own by
nature and if a team in some lab somehow
manages to create an AI That's conscious
and self-aware like in Sci-Fi movies
that team will win the Nobel
Prize for doing something that already
happened on its own by
Nature isn't there something totally
insane about some of the smartest people
in the world spending countless hours
and endless trunks of money to
accomplish something that supposedly
just happened on its
own hence AI only deepens the
mystery there are some physicists
working on the problem of Consciousness
trying to incorporate it into physics
that's a a fascinating one to me notice
he said physicists not
neuroscientists
neuroscientists study the brain why is
he bringing up physicists who study
Physics
I read about this several years ago in
the context of near-death experiences
there are numerous cases in medical
journals of people who are clinically
Dead showing no brain activity at all
being brought back to life and reporting
that they had conscious experiences
while they were dead thoughts feelings
desires and so on since people with no
brain activity can apparently still be
conscious it seems like Consciousness
goes beyond Beyond brain
activity certain physicists even some
important physicists have been trying to
figure out if there's some Quantum level
of Consciousness that might hold
together and function even if the brain
at the macro level isn't
functioning the takeaway for our
discussion is that there are physicists
who are working on the problem of
Consciousness because they recognize
that the story that we're all told is
probably
false if you held me if you held me over
a Chasm and asked me to tell you what I
believe I I kind of as as I get older I
kind of ascribe more to the what the
Buddhists have been saying all along uh
which is that Consciousness is a single
thing and we are all different aspects
of it Consciousness is a single thing
and we're all different aspects of it
we've all got a little part of the one
grand
Consciousness now he obviously doesn't
mean that there's one giant brain and
that our brains are all little parts of
that one giant
brain he obviously doesn't mean that
there's one giant network of neurons and
that we each get a little section of
that giant network of
neurons what's he
saying he's saying that Consciousness is
something very very different from what
we're told in science classes and that
he agrees with Buddhists not with
Scientists so no I don't think I'm
getting more mystical as I get older I
think I'm getting more articulate about
my mysticism as I get older he's not
getting more mystical he's getting more
articulate about his
mysticism but that means he's a Mystic
to some extent
right remember all that stuff he said
earlier about testable provable
phenomena remember when he defined
reason as the human capacity to make
sense of the
world reason is supposed to make sense
of the world but when it comes to
Consciousness Adam the mythbuster sides
with Buddhists and admits that he's a
Mystic in a weird way he's still being
scientific because he's recognizing that
a scientific hypothesis the hypothesis
that Consciousness is just a byproduct
of neural activity is failing he's
recognizing that the story we're all
told in school doesn't actually make
sense of the world in other words he
busted another myth a myth he wasn't
even trying to bust and so he's forced
to look elsewhere for the truth even if
the truth turns out to be a bit
mystical I would agree with Adam Savage
about there being some ultimate
consciousness
but my conclusion would be a bit
different I'd put it like
this if the materialistic naturalistic
view of the world were true human
consciousness would not exist because
the only explanations naturalists can
appeal to are particles energy and
natural
forces but human consciousness is
inexplicable in these
terms theists on the other hand believe
in a God our creator who's immaterial
invisible rational creative and
self-aware since the human mind is
immaterial invisible rational creative
and self-aware human consciousness fits
quite nicely into a theistic framework
where God creates not only a world of
physical bodies but also a world of
immaterial Souls
[Music]